now I don't know what it is about us
women but we just have an inclination to
never be happy and to nitpick and to
Wine you know a man men are just
generally more content with life like
they'll have a good job good benefits
and they'll say okay I'm a happy camper
but women just we have a tendency to
Wine it doesn't mean we're bad people
but I mean I think we can acknowledge
there's some pattern and one pattern I
noticed is women will want to be in a
man's world they'll say please let me
into a man's world oh please God please
God let me in I want to be in and then
they get in and they tell men how to
talk they start policing the language
you can't say that this is bullying da d
d d da